monday edition of pft ot where we get to
some of the things we didn't get a
chance to talk about during pro football
talk live and one of the things that i
caught wind of yesterday chris when
trying to get a better understanding of
why dak prescott decided to sign the
franchise tender with the dallas cowboys
another great young quarterback in texas
who has yet to get his second contract
and is trying to get it to sean watson
of the texans
my understanding is he's pushing for a
three-year extension and it is rare that
a quarterback who isn't on the wrong
side of 35 gets a contract that short in
duration now look no further than larry
mutunsel the left tackle for whom the
texans traded last year with the
dolphins he got a three-year extension
earlier this year putting him under
contract for four years if watson gets
his three-year extension he'll be under
contract for five total years but
usually a guy in this posture the team
wants four five or even maybe six years
for example patrick mahomes can end up
with a five or a six year extension on
top of the two that he already has under
contract with the chiefs watson
is expected to get out of these
negotiations if and when they conclude
with just a three-year extension which
really is amazing to me
and uh you know it's it's good for the
kid
it gets him back to the bargaining table
sooner rather than later the only risk
he's taking is
the injury and effectiveness make may
keep him from getting that next contract
yeah well it definitely could you're
right that's that's the risk you're
taking if you're deshawn watson but like
you know
again most players want these type of
contracts have you as you've explained
here you want to get back to where yeah
you can get back to the negotiating
table
and get another contract to where you
get more guaranteed money and a signing
bonus and that's money in your pocket
right away and you don't have to worry
about injured injuries and there's
security there you know the thing to me
mike with that kind of contract how do
they work this out you know you're
saying it's an extension so these last
two years of his rookie deal
are going to count on this right this
because watson's going into year four
all right so
um
so with this extension are we you think
we're talking like a kirk cousins total
guarantee
three-year type deal type of thing going
um well i mean again it's it's a
five-year total contract so i don't know
how much of it will be guaranteed will
the first three years be guaranteed
usually teams will only guarantee the
first two years but for some players
they get that third year guaranteed and
as a practical matter here's the thing
with quarterbacks you can guarantee the
whole thing right now
there's still an issue with the funding
rule and money has to be put into escrow
but rarely does a quarterback all of a
sudden lose it two or three years into a
contract once a quarterback shows he's
getting it done he's going to continue
to get it done and these quarterback
contracts are unlike other positions far
more likely to see a guy get all the way
through the life of the deal
uh and uh and that makes that that
urgency to extend it even farther but
kirk cousins is the best example from
the standpoint of getting three years
but for cousins it was a straight three
because he had all the leverage
for watson it's three years on top of
the two that he still has
um which which any any regardless of
whether a guy's got years left or not
chris any time that you can manage to
get a new contract and it only covers
three years is impressive
mike i mean listen again maybe i'm
stupid here
right so so when we're talking about a
three year extension onto the two years
what the fifth year option is that
that's considered already into this
that's considered as part of it it would
be three years on top of the two because
they have his rights they have his
rights through 2021 so it is five years
okay um all right but but but again i
the chiefs are gonna want five years on
top of the remaining two years from
patrick mahomes put him under under
contract for seven years so
that's why i think it's
you know at a time when we don't know
what the next wave of tv deals will
bring to the nfl we don't know how much
more money is going to be injected into
the overall revenue streams of the teams
and the salary caps
we assume
even though it's difficult to make that
assumption now because of the the
pandemic we assume that at some point uh
the money is going to be flowing again
and so you want to position yourself to
get back at the trough more often than
not because what happens is if you do a
five-year extension
right you have the guaranteed money the
first couple of years they keep you the
third year for cap reasons you get the
year four and five
those are team options when you get to
the non-guaranteed salaries and if they
keep you that means they think it's a
bargain if it's not a bargain they're
not keeping you so why not avoid those
last two phony years and get back to the
to the
to the bargaining table and get the
opportunity to get a new contract so i
like it very much that
that what deshaun watson is pushing for
here is only a three-year extension and
it's going to be uh for him
a valuable comparison to whatever
patrick mahomes eventually does because
no matter what mahomes locks into
watson's going to get back
into the position of getting a
renegotiation faster than than than
mahomes will yeah it's certainly i mean
it certainly seems that way you know the
thing that watson and you know first off
the houston texans are gonna have to
worry about here i mean you know i know
the
you know two years remaining on the deal
are gonna soften the blow but man it's
gonna be a lot of money between laramie
tonsil and deshawn watson certainly now
we can understand why they felt a need
to try to trade deandre hopkins and make
that type of move they couldn't pay you
know 22 million to a left tackle 22
million to a wide receiver and then
i don't know mike if you're gonna sign a
three-year deal
what type of money just in the new part
do you think we're talking here like at
this point he's obviously he is a guy
that i would say
classifies
to make more money than a russell wilson
or aaron rodgers are the guys that are
at the top of the market because
he's very close to if not as good or
better than them it's right in that
conversation i think in the class of
quarterbacks he's in and of course we
don't think any of us believe he's
reached his peak yet he's the guy that's
still going up so yeah to me uh this is
kind of funny where where is this going
to fall in line i mean you know how much
does he jump them by are we talking you
know three years 38 million per year
type of deal
on this extension
well i think here's the key the key is
you wait to see what happens with dak
you wait for july 15. if he does a
long-term deal that becomes your floor
because between the two you would put
desean watson had a dak prescott and i
have the evidence for that yeah the fact
that you have prescott at number eight
on your rankings and we haven't
mentioned desean watson yet so he's
higher than prescott so he's gonna make
more than prescott so if i'm watson what
i try to do
is wait for
dak to do his deal and then go ahead and
do mine and and go ahead and let mine be
the floor for patrick with homes because
they're not going to pay me more than
they're going to pay patreon homes but
push for a three-year extension push for
a million or two more per year than
whatever prescott gets and that's your
deal and it's a three-year extension
it's a five-year deal he's due to make
about
18-7
over the next two years anyway
under his uh last two remaining years of
his contract and see the thing is
for him the fifth year option is only
17.5 million only 17.5 million because
he wasn't a top 10 pick mahomes was a
top 10 pick for him that fifth year
option is significantly more um so
uh you know the the the new money
means more when the old money is less
than what it would be for a guy like
patrick mahomes
yeah yeah it definitely does uh you know
hey listen watson
watson is one of the the torch bearers
in the nfl i think he is one of those
guys this is this is next him lamar
jackson mahomes they are getting the
baton
to me from you know
drew brees brady
yeah aaron rodger yeah kyle murray would
be that aaron rodgers this is the next
generation of guy here and i think
deshawn watson and you and i would both
agree like yeah he's gonna be in my top
five quarterbacks of course he is and i
think he's gonna be there for a long
time i mean this guy's a superstar
there's just no other way around it
there's really nothing about his game he
can carry a team by himself we know he's
got tremendous tremendous work ethic you
know it's another guy that just embodies
everything you want you know as far as
the face of the franchise let alone he's
really special on the field like really
special um so you know it's well
deserved and i get it and i'm just uh
and you know really with the extension
part of it mike too
it could be a fairly
you know
what do i want to say a fairly good
number for the texans as far as the
organization's concerned about a not a
big yearly cap hit when you take into
account you know the fourth year of the
contract in the fifth year option
yeah look and it's going to be a
challenge to structure it in a way that
allows you to have enough money for
other players but the quarterback is the
centerpiece and he's the guy and you
know it wasn't all that long ago that
there was speculation that the deandre
hopkins trade would contribute to an
eventual parting of the texans and
watson and i remember and we talked
about it one day i don't think we talked
about it on the air but we were kicking
around the idea of including it in the
show
that there's a sports book out there
that that had sean watson as the
favorite to be the week one starter for
the patriots in 2021 which right
is ridiculous even without the extension
but once the extension happens that's
not gonna happen and hey when you get a
great young quarterback you do not let
him go and that's what the texans have
and this is a no-brainer you don't let
him go and you pay him and then you
you use the draft and all other devices
to put the players around him no that
that's right exactly right i mean this
is the kind of guy and talent that makes
your franchise you know it already has
made them relevant
and the type of team and guy that i
expect to keep his team relevant for the
next 10 years where they're always in
the playoffs or dancing around the
playoff conversation and i think like to
your point mike like billy o'brien
realizes i got something special here i
can't let this guy hit the open market
and i think
you know as much as we thought ooh maybe
this isn't good that deandre hopkins
left desean watson i think what it's
really done is allowed the texans to say
okay desean watson you're our guy oh we
love you you're so awesome you're our
man see we let go of deandre hopkins
because we want to pay you we want to
make you the marquee guy you're the best
guy on our team and franchise and all
that so i think in a lot of ways that
move even though it might not be the
best on the field
at least for watson to this point i
think it's only going to embolden the
franchise and him to feel like hey i am
the guy and they're going to fully
invest in me to make sure that happens
all right uh we'll see how that plays
out but i think that's the timeline
prescott by july 15.
watson after that regardless of whether
or not prescott does a long-term deal
and then we keep our eyes out for the
mahomes deal but plenty of young
quarterbacks who deserve it and are
going to be getting it you'll be getting
a new addition to pft live on tuesday
and uh plenty of content around the
clock at profootballtalk.com
chris great stuff as always everybody
else we'll see you tomorrow
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports